on peut dire que la pandémie a stimulé
l'achat local au cours des derniers mois
les initiatives comme le panier bleus
ont été mises de l'avant bien sûr pour
permettre la survie des entreprises ici
aujourd'hui l'association des fabricants
de meubles du québec lance une campagne
pour faire valoir cette industrie mon
invité jean-françois nolet et les pdg de
hub et meubles l'entreprise qui est
située à victoriaville au québec bonjour
bonsoir alain gautier oui bonsoir c est
ça me fait plaisir merci d'être là
d'abord comment s'est passé le début de
la pandémie pour votre entreprise et un
arrêt de production assurément oui tout
à fait ensuite comme plusieurs
entreprises ont eu des meubles n'était
pas une entreprise essentielle donc on a
dû arrêter les huit semaines
donc c est évidemment un moment
difficile attend cantona puisqu'on n'a
jamais un plan de sécurité d'opérations
qui peut pallier une pandémie une crise
sanitaire comme on a vu par contre
évidemment la fiabilité c'était bien
géré de notre côté avec l'équipe en
place
puis un message au niveau des employés
ticks et quel était le plus grand défi
au moment où on a repris les activités
est ce que c'est l'approvisionnement est
ce que c'est de pouvoir rattraper le
carnet de commandes
oui effectivement il ya eu plusieurs
facteurs c'était évidemment de repartir
lève donc au niveau de la sous traitance
de nous sous traitants au québec
évidemment la peau visionnement donc été
un petit peu plus difficile puisqu'on et
des composantes qui viennent aussi
d'europe pour penser le parti de là mais
ça c'est tout bénéf et finalement tout a
bien été
mais il domaine a fallu surtout aussi
remettre à jour le carnet de commandes
puisque la pandémie entre yves demeure
cosy annulations de commandes
certains des liens aussi qui ont
malheureusement fermé leurs portes aux
états unis donc des fal évidemment
remettre à jour l'ensemble des commandes
pour avoir le parti est juste ce qu'il
fallait fabriquer ou quoi et quand le
québec s'est mis sur pause et bien le
gouvernement a voulu encourager l'achat
local
il ya eu je disais d'entrée de jeu ce
panier bleus beaucoup d'engouement pour
certains secteurs parce que ça a été le
cas aussi pour le meuble
oui tu t'assieds je pense
qu'actuellement ce qu'on vit dans le
meuble la publicité qu'a fait le
gouvernement le veau de la chose locale
depuis le début de la pandémie d'être
fabriqués au québec salue évidemment
n'est pas pour nous
hu a généralement québec représente 35%
de notre carnet de commande au canada
15% au total de l'entreprise
actuellement le carnet commandes du
québec ses 45%
il faut comprendre que le canada est en
croissance et les états unis
et puisque ce qu'on vit actuellement
c'est une crise sanitaire donc le
consommateur qui ne pas perdre son
emploi continue d'avoir de l'argent il
ya un taux d'épargné élevé que c'est
facilement au crédit des bas taux
d'intérêt donc les gens qui sont pris à
la maison du revenu disponible pour les
biens durables ont donc durer comme ça
et puis comme les gens ont pu moins
voyagé beaucoup ont décidé d'investir
justement dans la maison dans leur chez
soi est ce que ça s'est aussi ressentie
pour ce qui est de l'achat des meubles
bleus finalement oui on ne venait pas
exactement on voit justement de
catégories plus aisément les gens
adaptent leur environnement de travail
donc nous on vend du mobilier venant de
bureau donc on voit qu'une tendance
lourde à ce niveau donc c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est que certains
qualifient produits qui sont un peu plus
élevé le niveau de l'achat mais ce qui
est certain aussi on voit que le
consommateur aussi et conscientiser le
plus en plus acheter des biens durables
de qualité fabriqués au québec
et puis c'est le message de cette
association l'a d'ailleurs il ya des
tabous qui disent qu'ils disent souvent
les meubles fait au québec sont vendus
plus chers
est-ce qu'il y en a pour tous les
portefeuilles monsieur nolin tout à fait
écouter chaque entreprise à son créneau
et on est quand on s'adapte très bien on
a des fabricants qu'ils vont aller
confessions et très bien des meubles
sont dans au niveau des prix asiatiques
ou des prix d'importation comme lors
d'autres qui ont compétitionné le coup
plus l'importation italien ce candidat
veut plus haut gamme dont je pense non
pour tous les goûts et toutes les
bourses
effectivement j'ai exercé
dès l'entrée de jeu l'industrie se
mobilise on veut convaincre encore
davantage de citoyens d'acheter des
meubles bleu des meubles d'ici pourquoi
cette campagne actuellement le but de la
campagne aussi et certains s'en est allé
mais c'était une campagne en tant qu on
voulait justement conscientiser
consommateurs à venir regarder chez nous
puis a demandé des meubles fabriqués au
québec et le but la campagne vient
chercher cette place là tout comme on
veut aussi mettre en oeuvre que les
détaillants de meubles affiche avec
fierté les mêmes fabriqué ici donc c'est
gagné pour tous puis on le voit
actuellement la crise nta permet
justement de concertiste le monde avec
la chaîne logistique brisé que ça donne
un avantage concurrentiel au québec qui
livre un bon de livraison
comparativement la ce qu'on a vécu dans
cette crise aussi que des fois des
conteneurs importés peuvent 16 wilcats
n'y ait plus de délai et puis c'est un
choix qui est un peu plus écologique
aussi parce qu'on diminue les transports
tout à fait jeter lapointe carbone est
excellente note environnementale
merci beaucoup monsieur nollet c'est un
fait plaisir c'est une belle soirée au
revoir au revoir